[Music]
good morning governor desantis
around here
um
don't say gay
don't say
as the first two words
in a sentence spoken by a political
leader of a state
in the united states of america don't
say
don't
say you nazi pig
say
first amendment
read about it
then run for office
you pieces
hey how are you that's a fun way to
start the show don't you think uh i'm
dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message it's march 30th 2022.
it's happy birthday
to my brother day march 30th 79
42 years old 43 years old now man we're
getting old you're catching up to me bro
um that was uh hollywood actor
ron perlman
with a ridiculous ridiculous
selfie video yelling
at florida governor ron desantis for
something that is completely made up in
ron perlman's head and i think the theme
of the show today will be enough
is enough it is time to fight back
against these freaks and their imaginary
problems
so of course we are live streaming on
rumble on youtube and on blaze tv do me
a favor subscribe all that good stuff uh
but you know over the last week or so
i've really been hitting hard on just
the ineptitude
of our government
our officials the lies of mainstream
media and i think maybe something's
turning right now i think so many people
are waking up so fast i think the the
curtain has been pulled back to the
point that so many people
are seeing what is really going on here
that it is time we start going on the
offense and ron desantis has been doing
that right here in florida so we're
going to be talking about this from this
idiotic don't say gay bill which by the
way uh ron perlman uh who if you're
watching and you don't know who ron
pelman is he's he's an actor he was in
hellboy what else was this guy in he was
in hellboy and hellboy too they weren't
so great can we google maybe what else
this guy was in i don't know what he was
in the guy needs an orthodontist more
than anything else that was the main
takeaway from the from the video there
um but this is what they do to people
they have broken
people
so deeply so profoundly that you have a
grown man
taking a selfie video that he sends out
to his over million twitter followers
right
and
he talks about don't say gay the
implication being that don't say or gay
is in the bill and it's not
it's not you guys know that we're going
to unpack it a little bit in just a
moment uh but then so he makes up what's
in the bill because the the media has
you know pushed this meme of don't say
gay out there and then not only does he
make it up and then his response or he
makes it up or he's been duped by the
made-up thing that the media pushes but
then his response is to call
ron desantis
a nazi
let me just tell you something about ron
desantis i actually i'm not saying this
to brag but i've met him a couple times
now since i've been in florida i was an
enemy of the state in california and now
i've hung out with the governor a few
times i actually had dinner with him and
a few other people last week
and the word gay was set at the table
it was
and the first lady wished me well uh
because we're having kids
these are good decent people who are
fighting massive corporations and it's
the individual versus the machine right
now and desantis is modeling the right
thing
these are bad guys he calls him a nazi
a nazi you ron perlman would be the nazi
so anyway the theme of the show today is
it's time to fight back there are there
are signals out there that are showing
us that fighting back is winning and
we're going to model a whole bunch of
that for you over the show today so it's
going to be desantis versus
disney
jon stewart who's gone fully woke it's
it's so depressing he was sort of a half
good liberal i suppose something like
that well now he's just gone all in on
like the anti-white hate and all just
the stupid woke [ __ ] on his show
that i guess is on apple tv i don't
think anyone's watching it but i did see
this one clip we got to show it to you
uh and then some covid stuff where uh
fauci is now admitting and and data is
coming out that they they just didn't
know what they were doing they have no
idea that anything
that they did work so that's what we're
doing today so buckle in people because
today today we're going on the offense
it's not just about commenting i try not
to do that in general it's not just
about commenting on what these people
are doing and exposing their nonsense
but now i think it's time for a shift
and the shift is we go on offense now
and and let's start beating these people
and these bad ideas because they they
deserve it uh and it's being done
correctly here in florida and speaking
of florida the tour the don't burn this
country tour kicks off in florida in
orlando on april 18th there are all the
dates i don't want to belabor it uh but
tickets are selling really fast
especially vip tickets you can go to
davereuben.com
events don junior's joining me uh
michael malus the on me parkland beck
megan mccain megan kelly whole bunch of
other people dennis prager larry elder a
lot of my good friends will add some
more people pretty soon and i look
forward to seeing you good people out
there and before we get to anything else
i want to talk to you about battle box i
have a giant bridal box man this thing's
heavy on
my desk right now you know how you're
gonna find your new favorite piece of
outdoor gear well if you sign up for
battle box it finds you battle box is
your go-to monthly subscription for
hand-picked outdoor survival and
everyday carry gear getting the best
gear for yourself not only takes time
but can be incredibly expensive that's
why battlebox brings you name brand high
quality products every month at half the
price of what they cost on their own
just pick the box that works for you and
get tested and vetted products you can
trust that are selected by an expert
team of outdoor professionals from an
aquapod emergency water kit which we
have to an atomic bear survival bivvy
delivered right to your doorstep each
month battlebox has shipped over a
million boxes since 2015 and has been
featured everywhere from the new york
times to survivor's edge david loves to
go camping and was excited to find the
high quality binoculars and a knife in
our box personally i'm worried about the
zombie apocalypse which is why i'm
always warning you people they're coming
for us all uh and we want to make sure
we have enough food in our house when it
happens so i was thrilled to receive
battle boxes 72 or 72 hour emergency
meal kit find out why outdoor
enthusiasts call battlebox the best gear
i never knew i wanted sign up receive
survive what are you waiting for don't
miss another battle box mission and from
now until march 31st that's tomorrow get
a free mystery box worth 115 bucks with
any new subscription at
trybattlebox.com
ruben that's free mystery box worth 115
bucks try battlebox.com ruben try
battlebox.com reuben and now back to me
okay
so
the
don't say gay
bill which doesn't have the words don't
say or gay in it it's actually called
hb1557
has officially
passed here in florida it has been
signed
by ron desantis
so first off why don't we just go
through
what is in the bill one more freaking
time
so first off there's the basic thing
that you cannot talk to children in
kindergarten through third grade about
gender identity or sexuality and if that
thing may if you think that's weird
then just i want you to picture what a
first grader would be doing talking to a
state employee about gender identity
really think about that try to picture
that in your mind a first grader a
six-year-old that you know and that that
state uh employee could then hide that
from the parents that's what they're
trying to get rid of that's all this is
really about but now please show that
image again it also adds a couple things
related to transparency which we should
all want notify parents of changes to
health or well-being of the kid of
course you would want that don't
encourage withholding information from
parents of course you would want that
allow parents to access child student
records yes the parents should know
what's going on at school let parents
refuse school healthcare services sure
the school does not own the child get
parental permission for health screening
these are all basic obvious things and
everything everything everything coming
out of hollywood coming out of the
corporate press coming out of the blue
czech journalists they lie about
everything we have
we've crossed the rubicon people
they've lied about a lot of stuff for a
long time but now there's nothing they
don't lie about like everything that i
talked to you about yesterday with biden
lying about everything the machine all
it has left is lies and defamation and
slander
and the rest of it that's all they got
left so here is florida governor ron
desantis
signing the bill into law and saying
that he ain't going anywhere
i don't care what corporate media
outlets say i don't care what hollywood
says i don't care what big corporations
say
here i stand
i'm not backing down
here i stand i'm not backing down
this is the individual verse the machine
this is the american story this is why
american
ingenuity has flourished because of
individual rights that the man
you the man the individual can stand up
to the man you get it and desantis is
doing it it's not fun to say i'm
fighting disney the biggest corporation
in the world that owns so much of our
cultural apparatus it's not a fun thing
like there's this feeling like i don't
know could disney destroy me like is
that is that really where we're at but i
think we all kind of feel that like if i
say something bad about disney i don't
know what disney's gonna do to me it's
like disney is the bad guy
in
a disney movie so he signs the bill
and he tells disney i am standing up
against you and by the way it's not just
that he's standing up against disney
as if they're just some company that
exists somewhere i mean disney florida
orlando it's like there's a lot of
floridians here that work for disney and
he's saying no i will do what's right
so then of course on cue
here is the statement from disney
florida's hb
1557 also known as the don't say gay
bill should never have passed and should
have never been signed into law our goal
as a company is for this law to be
repealed by the legislature or struck
down in the courts and we remain
committed to supporting the national and
state organizations working to achieve
that we are dedicated to standing up for
the rights and safety of
lgbtq plus members of the disney family
as well as the lgbtq
plus community in florida and across the
country
screw you disney
you're lying about what the bill is you
are being held hostage by a radical
group of leftist woke activists in your
own company and i hope i hope and
believe that they will actually destroy
your entire company because once
woke-ism is in a system we've seen this
at educational institutions we've seen
this at other corporations we've seen
this in our government once woke-ism is
in
and your your eye is off the ball right
you're not looking at what the goal is
what is the goal of an entertainment
company it should be to produce the best
entertainment to sell the most tickets
and that's what it should be but you
guys have decided that agenda matters
more than that and i hope it destroys
your whole [ __ ] kingdom i hope mickey
gets crushed by the pillar on top of
that stupid castle okay that's what you
people deserve at this point that is
what you deserve it is there is nothing
wrong with this bill
i happen to be gay big damn deal it just
it doesn't matter it's one thing about
me i'm married to a gay dude okay we're
having kids
regular gay people want nothing to do
with this thing what does being gay when
they say disney we're defending our lgbt
employees what does being gay
as an adult and entering a consensual
relationship with another adult where
now you can get married because we have
equality in america you can have a
family and all of those things what does
that have to do with a state employee
telling a kindergartner that their
gender and their biology does not match
what their gender identity could be and
then to hide that from their parents
these people are genuinely evil i i it's
extraordinary how evil they are and
they're doing it right in front of us
disney
are the bad guys they also have all
sorts of relationships in china we'll
get to that in just a minute uh but now
we have this incredible compilation it's
about a minute and a half disney had an
internal meeting of a ton of higher-ups
i'll tell you after we play the clip who
some of these people are but a ton of
higher-ups they did this internal
meeting about the don't say gay bill and
how they intend to continue
to to infect people with this woke
[ __ ] and it got exposed of course
because everything gets exposed of
course these days because things are on
zoom and everywhere else so just take a
look and listen to these series of
people
who uh they want your kids
last summer we removed all of the um
gendered greetings in relationship to
our life skills so we no longer say
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls um
we we've trained we we've provided
training for all of our our cast members
in relationship to that so now they know
it's it's hello everyone or hello
friends we we are in the process of
changing over those those recorded
messages and so many of you are probably
familiar when we brought the fireworks
back to the magic kingdom we no longer
say ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
we say dreamers of all ages i'm here as
a mother of two queer children actually
um uh one transgender child um
um and one pansexual child um and and
also as a leader
many many many lgbtqia characters
in our stories and and yet we don't have
enough
leads
um and narratives in which gay
characters just just get to be
characters on my little pocket of like
you know proud family disney tva um
the showrunners were super welcoming
meredith roberts and like the our
leadership over there has been so
welcoming to like my like not at all
secret gay agenda and so like i i feel
like
i felt like it was i mean like maybe it
was that way in the past but i guess
like something must have happened in the
last like like they are turning it
around they're going hard let's have
these two characters kiss let's in the
background like i was just wherever i
could just basically adding queerness to
like if you see anything queer in the
show i'm proud of them but like i just
was like no one would stop me and no one
was trying to stop me we're also
reacting from the reality that
when they can erase you when they can
criminalize your existence when they can
demonize who you are
the next step
is to criminalize you and take your kids
and we're already seeing that in texas
so the slippery slope between these ugly
messages
um
you know emanating from legislative
leaders in our state and then amplified
by our governor whose spokesperson
immediately began calling everyone who
opposed this bill
uh groomers aka pedophiles yeah um i've
had the privilege of working with the
moon girl team for the last two years
and they've been really open to
exploring queer stories and so i put
together like a tracker of our
background characters to make sure that
we have like the full breadth of
expression and uh we got into a very
similar conversation carrie of like oh
all of our
like gender non-conforming characters
are in the background
okay
so who are these people that just spoke
there i'm just going to break it down
real quick the woman who said that
they're not going to use gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
anymore that's disney's diversity and
inclusion manager vivian ware she's up
there she has a ridiculous amount of
power because all the kids that were
going to disney and that you know before
you get on the ride they were going boys
and girls line up get on the ride that
was actually causing hate and there were
all sorts of hate crimes they were
murdering children apparently because of
that the next lady who said that she has
a transgender child and a pansexual
child i don't know what that has to do
with her work at a giant corporation
that's disney corporate president carrie
burke
um so congratulations you have those
kids that's just fine with me i don't
have a problem with gay people actually
i think it's a perfectly uh normal part
of society there are gay animals they
are gay human beings it's it's part of
the experience right it's it's an
outlier sexuality but it's part of the
thing but you think because you have
these kids that somehow that should
infect all of your work uh the next
person was disney executive producer
latoya avenue she said that she's
implementing her not so secret gay
agenda into all of the movies again this
has nothing to do with being anti-gay
but do you want your children to be
propagandized by people that are telling
you that they are activists and if
even remove gay from this whatever that
they would want to propagandize to your
children whatever thoughts they would
want your children to have they're
saying hey we operate
as a propaganda
outlet not as an entertainment outlet uh
the next person was disney's activism
partner nadine smith of equality
california she said that they want that
desantis wants to erase you criminalize
your existence and take your kids uh
again i had dinner with him last week um
there was no moment of taking my kids or
criminalizing me i had the stake it was
pretty good actually we went to this
place flaglers in west palm beach it was
really excellent i had a i had a
tomahawk they seared that thing just
freaking perfectly and desantis made
sure that i had dessert so uh that's
that's the reality of what's going on
here i want to give a quick shout out to
uh chris ruffo who you guys know he's
been on the show many times who is
exposing most of this i think he was the
one that got this video because he gets
all of these leakers at these companies
to send him videos and it's important to
know what these people are doing this
has nothing to do with being prejudiced
towards gay people this has nothing to
do with breaking up gay families or not
allowing a kid to say i have two dads or
that the parents can't come to the play
at the school or anything else this is
about transparency in education and
making sure that state employees cannot
infect children with whatever their
ideas are and then hide it from the
parents but unfortunately we don't have
a mainstream media that is honest we
have a corporate press that is a
propaganda outlet for a bunch of woke
lunatics and then guys like me have to
do this uh but we can fight back
we can fight back and you guys are
fighting back people are fighting back
glenn younkin won in virginia over this
over critical race theory it's connected
to all of these things it's connected to
the gender stuff right he ran against
critical race theory and he ran against
vocism and he won the governorship in
virginia so there are wins but before i
fully move on uh i decided to take not
just just talk about this stuff but to
actually do something so you know what i
did this morning i cancelled disney plus
and many of you may say dave why did you
have disney plus and i was trying with
star wars and you know what mandalorian
wasn't that great boba fett really
wasn't that great but i mostly had it
because i have we have young nieces and
nephews and when they come over i wanted
them to be able to watch but you know
what we're gonna get a stick i'm gonna
go out into the backyard we're gonna
find a stick and when the kids come here
well they can jump in the pool if they
want or they can play with the stick
outside enough is enough enough is
enough stop paying these people stop
giving them your money and your
attention and your time
you don't have to give it to me but
don't give it to them i really mean that
i really mean that enough is enough
cancel them don't go to their movies
anymore don't buy their crappy
overpriced products they destroyed star
wars they destroyed my childhood dreams
that's what they did and now they want
to infect and control you and you want
to go there and spend
i think the new star wars land that they
have now which which supposedly sucks is
5 000
a night for a family of four yeah these
people really care about you
but fight back and how do you do it you
model this guy because here's desantis
more
uh even more so going off on disney for
disney to come out and put a statement
and say
that the bill should have never passed
and that they are going to actively work
to repeal it
i think juan was fundamentally dishonest
but two i think that crossed the line
this state is governed by the interests
of the people of the state of florida it
is not based on the demands
of california corporate executives they
do not run this state they do not
control this state and then for them to
say they're going to actively work
to repeal substantive protections for
parents as a company that is supposedly
marketing its services to parents with
young children uh i think they crossed
the line and you know people ask me you
know kind of about you know their
posture on the bill i said you know what
if we would have put in the bill
that you were not allowed to have
curriculum
that discussed the oppression of the
uyghurs in china disney would have
endorsed that in a second
and that's the hypocrisy of this and um
you know we're going to make sure we're
fighting back when people are
threatening our parents and threatening
our kids
you get it fight back and i do want to
address one specific thing he said there
uh which is that they're going to work
to overturn this legislation that's what
disney said
disney is a giant corporation
what right does it have to go against
the will of the people of the state the
legislature which writes the laws and
the executive the governor who signs the
laws
in this state what right do they have
they are not our overlords
but these corp and i thought the i
thought the people i thought the meme
out there was that corporations are bad
right what do we always hear from the
lefties bernie corporation's a bird
elizabeth warren cardboard [ __ ] that man
that was my elizabeth warren that wasn't
so good uh but the bernie was playing
the corporations
i thought corporations are bad but oh i
guess corporations are good when it
comes to
you know injecting this insane leftist
woke [ __ ] right it's just enough of
all of this but it's infected everything
with hollywood and that's why we have to
cancel and move on from all of these
things and i mean cancel this i don't
mean cancel culture destroy human beings
which is what they do and try to infect
me i mean stop giving them their your
money and stop paying attention to them
so we're going to get to a little bit
more on woke hollywood in just a sec but
i want to talk to you about cozy earth
because i'm fired up and one thing
that's nice when you're fired up is to
get into a nice pair of cozy pants
people if you appreciate the softness
and comfort of truly luxury bedding
you're gonna love today's sponsor cozy
earth cozy earth is renowned for
offering the softest most luxurious
environmentally friendly and ethically
produced bedding today so it's not
surprising that cozy earth has received
thousands of five-star ratings like this
recent review from carol who'd have ever
thought of a set of sheets could make a
difference in how you sleep the first
night i used the sheets i slept straight
through and every night since no more
overheating waking tossing and turning
just incredible sleep cozy earth sheets
are made from the finest luxury
materials including stock soft viscous
from highly sustainable bamboo and their
bedding is not only super soft
lightweight and breathable but
temperature regulating too so you sleep
at the perfect temperature year round i
love this stuff i truly truly do the
sweatpants the sweatshirts the whole
thing cozy earth even offers a 100 night
sleep trial which means you have 100
nights to sleep on it watch it try it
out if you're not completely in love
just send it back for a full refund and
for a limited time you can save 35 off
on cozy earth just go to cozyearth.com
dave and enter code dave at checkout to
save 35 now that's cozyearth.com dave
and be sure to enter david checkout for
35 off and now back to me okay so more
from hollywood because all it does
is choke out propaganda so you guys
remember john stewart jon stewart was
the host of the daily show for about 20
years uh 18 19 20 years something like
that a little known fact some of you may
know this i actually interned at the
daily show in 1999
uh when jon stewart had just taken over
you may remember that craig kilbourne
who was a former espn anchor a guy i
really loved in college he was the first
host of the uh the daily show and then
john took over it was a very weird time
to be there because there was a lot of
turnover they were firing a lot of
people their senses of humor were
different so there was a lot of churn
there but it was it was a formative
experience i was doing stand up at night
i was interning there during the day i
was working at electronics boutique
which you now know as gamestop uh in my
free time so i could have a little
little money eat some food i was eating
a lot of tuna back then i'll probably
die of a mercury overdose because that's
all i could afford
in any event over the 20 years that john
stewart hosted the uh the daily show you
know there was a idea out there that
this is where young people get their
news and it's that's what everyone kept
saying this is where young people get
their news and it was a culturally
important
show right and then you know and he was
sort of a
basically a good liberal like sort of it
was before woke-ism really uh he
completely went in on trump derangement
syndrome and then he dipped out
uh as trump had his four years so he
kind of went away for a while now he's
back apparently with a show on apple tv
and he's gone full woke he's gone full
woke these lefties and this is like the
bill maher thing i always talk about
they just don't know when to stop
and thus
the problem with white people
hold on
i'm just gonna
i'm just
i'm just gonna stop for a second and and
pose so you can get your memes out okay
there we go
get a good picture for you click beats
for however sincerely we want to reckon
and listen
the truth is america has always
prioritized white comfort over black
survival
it's such boring [ __ ] and trust me
it went on and on and on and he had a
ridiculous panel
where he was basically applauding as a
white woman was calling a white woman
who seemingly didn't know she was white
calling all white men evil this stuff is
so yes america has always been based on
white comfort all the men who died in
coal mines and who were laying track and
died and got burned in horrible
accidents in oil rigs and all of those
things it was all done in the name of
white power so that white comfort
ultimately could rule the day this is
the best maybe not for much longer and
you freaks are doing a pretty good job
of destroying it this is the best
country in the history of the world jon
stewart give up your show man what are
you doing you're a white dude you're a
white dude okay uh maybe you should give
up your show and give it to a black guy
is there not some black guy that could
do comparably what you do you're
pandering woke [ __ ] what are you
doing why are you taking the 10 million
bucks i'm sure it's got to be at least a
10 million a year deal from apple tv
right that's a lot of money why don't
you give it to a black guy but you're
not going to do that colbert you're not
going to do that jimmy kimmel you're not
going to do that you're just going to
tell white people how horrible they are
and it's like man
i've just had it with these freak
freaking people but the funny thing
about jon stewart is the same thing as
bill maher which is he sometimes kind of
gets it and then you see all these
people that are like oh my god he kind
of gets it he's a liberal who's not a
complete [ __ ] it's a miracle my god we
should somebody should say something
it's so wonderful you may remember a
couple months back i believe this was
june when jon stewart was on uh the
colbert show and even though for a year
and a half a whole bunch of us were
saying uh do you think that maybe covid
was a lab leak well jon stewart said it
on colbert and then suddenly everyone
was allowed to talk about it i think we
owe a great
debt of gratitude
to science science
has in many ways helped ease
uh the suffering of this pandemic
which was more than likely caused by
science
so there's a chance that this was
created in a lab there's an
investigation a chance well
i don't i i i i oh my god evidence i'd
love to hear there's a
novel respiratory coronavirus overtaking
wuhan china what do we do oh you know
who we could ask the
wuhan novel respiratory coronavirus lab
the disease is the same name as the lab
that's just that's just a little too
weird don't you think and then i asked
those scientists they're like how did
this so wait a minute you work at the
wuhan respiratory coronavirus lab how
did this happen and they're like a
pangolin kissed a turtle
there's been an outbreak of chocolatey
goodness
near hershey pennsylvania what do you
think happened like oh i don't know
maybe a
steam shovel mated with a cocoa bean or
it's the
chocolate factory
maybe that's it that could be
all right i don't know is he funny
anymore like i don't know it's not for
me to say like it's just
it is what it is but the point is that
after that suddenly mainstream media
said we were allowed to talk about the
the lab leak before that people were
getting banned from twitter kicked off
facebook shadow band the rest of it from
all of the social media sites for even
questioning that maybe there was a lab
leak
maybe there was a lab leak that led to
all of this so so john gets some stuff
right but he's unfortunately this is
what happens and there's a reason
there's an entropy to it why do so many
of the supposed good liberals or these
people who are not complete idiots i i
don't think john in his heart is a
complete idiot i really don't i think
he's probably mostly a decent guy but
once you go into that thing on the left
once you go into collectivism once you
go into wokism there's nothing you can
do to defend yourself against it because
now you have to bow because at the end
john you are now a i don't know 60 year
old white guy
you are a six year old white guy so you
know you have to bow to the activist
base so give up your show i really mean
that give up your show
give up your show or at least john you i
have no doubt i mean you must be worth
50 million bucks at least give up 20
million bucks to help young black tv
hosts get shows
if you really believe any of this but
none of them believe any of it he just
want clicks i don't know is anyone
watching apple do people pay for apple
tv that's a thing people pay for
ridiculous but anyway speaking of cove
it all continues it all continues
because anthony fauci the man we were
not allowed to question
for two years the man who lied about
masks lied about social distancing lied
about what the nih was doing in wuhan
all of the stuff well now he's kind of
admitting that he doesn't even know if
lockdowns worked i'm interested in your
reluctance to use the word lockdown do
you think two years on that they were
worth it or were they too severe
you know i don't think we're ever going
to be able to determine what the right
balance is i think the restrictions if
you want to use that word which i tend
to shy away from
lockdown this certainly prevented a lot
of infections prevented a lot of
hospitalizations
and prevented a lot of deaths there's no
doubt
about that
obviously when you do have that kind of
restriction on society
there are unintended
negative consequences particularly in
children who are not allowed to go to
school
in the psychological and mental health
aspects it has on children
in the economic stress that it puts on
society in general on individual
families
obviously those are
that
negative
consequ
or are they intended you freak so when
he talks about it prevented lockdowns
and prevented infection hospitalization
hospitalization and death notice as
always he never gives you numbers how
many hospitalizations did it prevent
lockdowns locking people in their houses
it doesn't tell you that how much how
many people didn't die because of it
doesn't tell you that cause he doesn't
have data on that and when he talks
about the unintended consequences was it
not obvious from beat one if you locked
people down that alcoholism rates were
going to go up and drug use was going to
go up and depression and all sorts of
stuff that we have seen i mean crazy
rates of all of these things and i'd
love to see numbers on how many more
people are on prescription pills these
days as opposed to two years before
although i'm sure he would love that mr
science over there and what this all
proves is that desantis again i'm trying
to show you that there is a way to fight
back and it starts with the individual
because desantis is just one man
there is a way to fight back and what it
shows you is that when when all hell was
breaking loose some people didn't
completely lose their minds and in
florida they didn't completely lose
their mind so if any of it worked
if any of it worked the rates of covid
and death and hospitalizations and all
this stuff would have been completely
out of control here in florida and
completely under control in california
and you know what from all the studies
that i've seen and i welcome you to show
me counter studies it's been pretty much
comparable pretty much comparable on top
of the fact that florida has the second
oldest population in the united states
okay so they have lied about everything
and that's all they can do that's all
they can do and uh if you think dave
well no they don't lie about everything
they wouldn't just make up numbers and a
whole bunch more on that well first i've
got some info here on just generally
what has happened with covid this is
from the daily wire more than half of
americans 52 say they have contracted
the virus according to a new monmouth
university poll this appears to be the
first poll to show a majority of
americans saying they've been infected
at some point an august poll from the
pew research center showed that 30
percent had tested positive or were
pretty sure they'd contracted the virus
uh okay so that means a whole bunch of
people got it in states that did lock
down and didn't lock down and you know
what 99.9 whatever percent of people
survived and everyone should take
whatever precautions they think are
necessary but now back to the line
because they do lie about everything
you're not going to admit this the cdc
yeah they bungled the numbers they're
they're admitting it now we've got more
from the daily wire here the center for
disease control updated its covid19
death statistics last week revealing
that the agency had included an
additional 72 000 deaths 72 000 deaths
that should not have been counted as
covid deaths the change impacted 26
states and all age groups the cdc
explained in a footnote that the
overcount stemmed from a coding logic
error yeah they forgot to carry the one
with a total of about 970 000 deaths
from covet 19 the extra death
the extra deaths compose about 7.5
percent of that number that ain't no
small number
416 extra pediatric covet 19 deaths also
represent a significant revision from
the initial data the question of how to
differentiate between how many deaths
were from coven 19 and how many deaths
were
deaths were with covid19 still remains
meaning that if you went to the hospital
and you had some other infection or
something else that was going to kill
you but you also had covet they would
just chalk it up to coven but okay so
there they lied all along about what
they were doing and whether it was
working or not they never really tell
you the numbers they fudge all the
statistics and now they're admitting oh
we had a coding error at the cdc you
know somebody is anyone going to be
fired is anyone going to be reprimanded
no no no because the machine is evil
people
okay i just realized i haven't taken a
breath in in six minutes all right so
let's uh let's recap the show today
there's a lot of weird stuff out there
there really is uh we are fighting
corporations we are fighting what
seemingly
are inept governments and officials and
all of those things
but do you know what we have
we have the individual
we have our own free minds there are
places in this country where that still
flourishes we still
even if it's hampered have the ability
to communicate with each other through
these pipes but we must build new things
we must build new entertainment outlets
the daily wire's doing a hell of a job
of it the blaze is doing a hell of a job
of it i think we're doing a hell of a
job of it we must build new technology
rumble's doing a hell of a job of it
locals is doing a hell of a job of it we
need new payment processors
we need we need
everything literally everything we need
to figure out how if you don't want to
be a cog in this very very evil machine
that you must find a way to do business
with people you want to do business with
i'm not for jailing these people i'm not
for destroying them and and
pushing them to the margins of society i
just don't want anything to do with them
and i am going to continue to devote my
life to making sure that a flourishing
america
and it starts here in a flourishing
florida exists
and
that's what we have to push on
and desantis is just one guy you know i
know i talk about him a lot here but
it's like one guy is saying enough's
enough
one guy is saying a pharaoh no
let my people go like it's enough of
this enough of this and i know you've
got power and i know you've got armies
and i know you've got big tech and i
know you've got corporations and i know
you've got the media and you can lie and
slander
and and seemingly destroy all of us but
if that's why you're not saying anything
then you're digging your own grave
because it will only get worse it's your
silence that acquiesces to it right it's
your silence that feeds it so that it
keeps moving and moving and moving so
it's us versus the mob it's us versus
the mob and the mob guess what the mob
it's powerful and it eats people that
otherwise sort of get it it eats people
like bill maher it eats people like jon
stewart that's not an attack on them but
they they're yes it's white people that
are the problem
we live in the most tolerant society
probably in the history of the world
we really really do
the only people who are really
intolerant right now are the woke
leftists and yes there are some on the
right there are there really are they
have no institutional power they have no
institutional power
but are there some racists are there
some old-school white supremacist
racists somewhere
are there people who really have true
bigotry in their heart that are that are
more right leaning or whatever you want
to call that of course there are
um but we are all being disregulated we
are being disregulated by algorithms and
bots and trolls and all of these things
and we need to figure out a way to win
this battle i think i think desantis is
doing it just by saying here i am here
is what i believe
um i am trying to say here i am here is
what i believe
i think if you do it whatever that means
to you whatever small step you can take
we can do this no one else is going to
save you no one is going to save you
guys
i got a book tour coming out
daveruban.comevents you can see me in
orlando and west palm and raleigh north
carolina and brea and oxnard and a whole
bunch of other places don junior's
joining me megyn kelly you know the
spiel already
daverubin.com we're adding more vip
seats i think at all the venues because
they a bunch of them sold out real quick
i think they'll be more added a little
bit later today as always if you want to
chat
during the show you can join us at
reubenreport.locals.com
part two of my interview with the
original
wolf of wall street the real wolf of
wall street it was not leo it was jordan
belfort uh that is up on youtube right
now the full things up at
reubenreport.locals.com and we've got a
cold clothes for you cause desantis he
was just nailing it across the board and
while uh people like bill maher are
basically saying that clarence thomas
the supreme court justice clarion's
house is just a token just a token black
guy there should be a black seat for the
token black guy well desantis had a
little something else have a great day
everybody i will say clarence thomas
greatest living justice and one of the
greatest public servants in america